[Música]
hola bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con en
momentos en que américa latina avanza
con campañas de vacunación más lentas
que las llevadas a cabo en eeuu y europa
el anuncio de la alta eficacia de las
vacunas cubanas y el estudio de oxford
que respalda la posibilidad de
vacunación mixta representan para muchos
expertos una esperanza para la región
para analizar este tema saludamos al
doctor oscar franco epidemiólogo
director del instituto de medicina
social y preventiva de la universidad de
berna académico de harvard y de la
universidad erasmo de rotterdam y
nuestro asesor científico por supuesto
gracias doctor por acompañarnos
comencemos en cuba' este país anunció
hace una semana que su candidata
vacunada la tiene una eficacia por
encima del 92 por ciento después de tres
dosis y la soberana 02 una eficacia del
62 por ciento después de dos dosis como
analiza estos resultados
dos palabras sobre estos resultados la
primera esperanza y la segunda cautela
esperanza porque ahora mismo cuba y
latinoamérica está experimentando la
peor el peor episodio de toda la
pandemia y las vacunas podrían ayudar
mucho aunque no van a resolver la
situación solas además cuba tiene
historia de producir productos tienen la
infraestructura sin embargo lo recibo
con cautela porque estos datos aún no se
han publicado en revistas científicas no
sabemos qué tan riguroso ha sido la
investigación y ha faltado transparencia
y sabemos que estos crudos
estos productos se tienen que evaluar
objetiva y rigurosamente antes de que
sean autorizados para aplicarlos en la
población
doctor en los países de américa latina
donde la distribución de vacunas avanza
lentamente en comparación con eeuu y
europa se podría pensar por ejemplo en
aplicaciones mixtas de vacunas
si es necesario tenemos una necesidad
importante porque hay miles de personas
en latinoamérica que han recibido o
sputnik o si novak otro producto y están
esperando hace semanas quizás meses para
recibir recibir la segunda dosis y
sabemos que dos dosis son fundamentales
para poder proteger así que es
importante utilizar quizás unos
programas de combinaciones de vacunas
sin embargo hasta ahora solamente
tenemos evidencia con una combinación de
astrazéneca y fisher justamente este
tema de las aplicaciones mixtas de
vacunas está soportado por un reciente
estudio de la universidad de oxford que
dice que una dosis de facer aplicada
cuatro semanas después de una de
astrazéneca puede generar una mejor
respuesta de inmunidad qué opinión le
merece este estudio
realmente ese estudio con golf de oxford
tenía cuatro grupos de evaluación uno
recibía astrazéneca y astrazéneca dos
dosis
el otro facer y pzifer y el otro
astrazéneca y fisher fisher y
astrazéneca realmente lo resultado lo
que están mostrando es que los tres
grupos que incluyen alguna vacuna de
facer o las dos son los que tienen los
mejores resultados esto confirma en
primer lugar que fallecerá es un
producto superior y segundo que se
pueden combinar las vacunas y entonces
nos puede ofrecer una oportunidad para
para poder facilitar esos problemas que
tenemos sin embargo aún no tenemos
resultados de combinaciones entre
sputnik y por ejemplo si novak y otros
productos y es fundamental porque son
las vacunas que más están aplicando en
latinoamérica bueno y la inoculación
mixta que valga la pena recordarlo es
recibir dos inyecciones de diferentes
vacunas supondría una mayor protección
contra las nuevas variantes que son más
agresivas del coi 19
el estudio de konko se hizo cuando la
variante alfa estaba era la variante
predominante en el reino unido- entonces
no sabemos ahora mismo si se podrían
obtener los mismos resultados con la
variante delta lo que sí sabemos es que
la variante de alta pues se tiene que
cubrir con dos dosis de vacuna es una
sola dosis no es suficiente entonces por
eso es tan importante tener estas dos
dosis ya sea una combinación o dos dosis
de una misma vacuna en una combinación
homóloga o una combinación heteróloga y
el estudio de oxford está analiza
también la importancia de los intervalos
entre una dosis y otra por ejemplo que
un intervalo más largo de tiempo entre
dos vacunas de astrazéneca puede ser más
efectivo porque sea esta situación
esto podría tener un beneficio porque la
primera dosis lo que hace es preparar al
sistema inmune para poder responder a la
segunda dosis parece que si se admite el
balón más largo entonces el organismo
puede madurar mejor esa preparación y
responder mejor a la segunda 2 sin
embargo hay dos inconvenientes al
respecto el primero es de logística
entonces extraer a las personas después
de dos meses o tres meses y tratar de
devolverlos a traer para la segunda
vacuna y la segunda es la más importante
que es de prevención porque vemos que la
variante de alta por ejemplo que ahora
mismo amenaza con ser la variante
predominante necesita de dos dosis para
poder proteger entonces si llegamos a la
población con una sola vacuna pues están
vulnerables al doctor oscar franco
muchas gracias a ustedes también por su
sintonía siguen france24
[Música]